it's been a crazy week in america let's
find out what happened
ukraine was attacked this week by
russian forces and republicans know just
who to blame for it
russia announced that it had destroyed
more than 70 military targets in ukraine
which is a weird flex but then again
putin is known for flexing
poor horse
the hollywood reporter published a list
this week of the 24 best presidents in
film and tv which included morgan
freeman in deep impact and chris rock
and head of state and president biden in
this film
two hops this time
[Applause]
oh my god
you guys
you'll never be able to play
the amount
that this actually happened it went on
for so long
guys
and now
you can go ahead and take a look for
that clip every show i'll never get
enough of it
texas governor greg abbott on tuesday
ordered the state's child protective
services to investigate all trans
children and to prosecute their parents
as child abusers he also ordered the
general public to start reporting any
transgender children they see well you
heard the man the law says everyone in
texas has to start reporting trans kids
to authorities so it's only right that
we give you some tips on how to identify
any trans children that might be in your
midst
tip number one the children so keep your
eyes peeled for anyone short vulnerable
and in no way a threat to you whatsoever
if you see someone that fits this
description there's a real possibility
that they are a trans child call the
cops
tip number two
they look and act like everyone else
so if you see a child acting totally
normal there's a chance they're trans
warning signs may include playing
hopscotch giving cooties shots and
having dimples
if you see a child doing any of these
things place a hysterical call to 9-1-1
tip number three
they are afraid trans people have a
nearly one in 10 chance of being
physically attacked in any given year
that's a real fear they carry with them
every day so if you see a trans kid make
things worse for them and call the fbi
tip number four they're experiencing
homelessness transgender and other lgbtq
identified youth make up 20 to 40
percent of the homeless kids in our
country so if you notice a young person
struggling to find housing do what jesus
would do
call a swat team tip number five
they're tired of your [ __ ]
trans kids are all different unique
perfect human beings but they all have
one thing in common they're tired of
hateful adults inserting themselves into
their business so if you see a child who
seems exhausted by your [ __ ] it is
possible that they are trans call your
congress person tell them to call the
president because that's a code red
and hey
make sure to do it now before you
realize how utterly obsolete you are and
how the world has moved past its need
for you
or you could off back to the monologue
google wrist i hurt my hand while i was
pounding but it was so great it was so
impassioned i believed you
did it it still hurts i should have done
that google
recently rolled out a new version of its
so-called dark mode that changes the
theme from dark gray to true black now
you can tell if you're in true black
because your screen will look like this
it's black you know huh
it's a nancy pelosi screen too
[Applause]
slide to the left
slide
according to a new survey
40 of americans said they don't enjoy
gossiping at all said the other 60
what is their deal
the kids animated series arthur ended
this week after 25 years it taught kids
pretty much everything except what an
aardvark looks like
george washington's birthday was this
week so celebrate by being a terrible
person and then covering it up with a
charming antidote about a cherry tree
and finally i said antidote but it's
antidote
antidote antidote
you say it i thought antidote was what
you take if you're poisoned and that's
antidote
antique dote was that just poisoned yes
there's only one cure crisscross
fly to the left
side to the right
and finally authorities in denmark asked
the public this week for help locating a
loose kangaroo so if you've never seen a
loose kangaroo here's one
and that was the monologue did you guys
like the monologue
i'm glad you like it because we have a
no return policy
now there have been so many people who
have contributed to black history in
really big ways and i'm sure you know
their names but i want to kick off our
celebration tonight by taking a moment
to celebrate some lesser-known black
people who have made black history in a
segment called black history baby
[Music]
this is vanetta flowers in 2002 she
became the first black athlete from any
country to win a gold medal at a winter
olympics she inspired so many we'd love
to see it that's black history baby
this is judge katanji brown jackson she
is the first black woman nominated to
the supreme court of the united states
that
that just happened today
she is making history in front of our
eyes
black history baby
this is the fresh prince in 1990 he got
in one little fight and his mom got
scared and said you're moving with your
auntie and uncle in bel air um
amber that's a character from a tv show
he was also the first prince to drive
across country in a cab that had dice in
the mirror now that's black history bibi
now this
this is jane cook wright in 1971 she
became the first woman to be named
president of the new york cancer society
a pioneer we salute her despite all odds
she rose to the top now that's a
blickety black history baby
and this
this is susie carmichael she was the
first black child to stand up to
angelica pickles in her own home
amber
i'm sorry amber that's a cartoon
character was she voiced by a black
woman yes but bats but black eye
herstory baby
now this is kermit
amber that is a little green frog and
i'm pretty sure he is voiced by a woman
eric
did black people successfully turn this
innocent clip of kermit drinking from a
mug into an epic meme that means
spilling the tea
yes but then
that's black
now
these are the numbers one two and three
okay
okay amber those are just numbers yes
but one is like a dream come true too
just want to be with you three because
it's plain to see that you're the only
one for me
that's from the brian mcknight song back
at one and that titan
is black history
okay
okay all right
you know what
you know what i want to do one this is
lebron james oh that's a good one yeah
he's one of the most successful athletes
of all time he led his basketball team
to victory against the goon squad and
the greatest sports achievement since
michael jordan defeated the monstars in
the 90s
you know what i'm not going to argue so
fast
history
[Music]
black history month is a time to
celebrate heroes who fought hard for
civil rights a lot of them are dead and
their stories are sad but i'd like to
take a minute out of black history month
to remember someone who is very much
alive zaila avangard she is the perfect
little sweetie who captured our hearts
not long ago by being the first african
american to win the scripps national
spelling bee scrimps
yeah
and when she won she did this
that is correct
she is so cute twirling around like that
she was also named sports illustrated
sports kid of the year and she holds
three guinness world basketball records
she is an elite unicyclist and juggler
and i'm not making up any one of those
things these are all real things about
her so i just want to take a moment out
of our show to say that i think she is
amazing yeah
so
she she won the spelling bee huh um what
word
maria
m-u-r-r-a-y-a
[Music]
m-u-r-r-a-y-a is how you spell you did
great
m-u-r-r-a-y-a
spells she got a lot on your plate
you're not really playing guitar i'm
nowhere near as talented as she is
you got a bunch of world records cause
you're such a good athlete
once i attempted
to play a sport
and i broke both my feet
i'm exaggerating but like barely
[Music]
m-u-r-r-a-y-a is how you spell good job
[Music]
m-u-r-r-a-y-a spells compared to you i'm
a slob what does that word even mean ah
i'm not as smart as that child
you've been doing your best to we're so
impressed we don't know where to start
when you twirl with joy i gotta say oh
boy it just fills up my heart
cool huh yeah she's really cool
m u r r a y a it's how you spell it i
think you're the greatest
so ela's the greatest
we think you're the greatest
do you think she'll see this
she don't watch this show it's on past
her bedtime
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you